hello and welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv and movie channel i was like
doing a little pause between
me
and i always do a little
kick to the head and
move your channel i'm like a terrier
yeah like a little terry i'm such a
happy
good evening shelly hello iron bear how
are we i am doing well
here in southern california
yeah how's the weather in california is
it rains yeah
uh
like ever dreary cloudy a little bit on
cool side
and that's about it no earthquakes in
the last 24 hours here that's that's
always nice i tell you what i i have
it's a good day for me in britain when
um we don't have earthquakes i think
that's my um because they never happen
um
but we haven't seen the sun in a while
so that's a problem well it's still
there i guarantee you it's still there
it's still there
it keeps throwing storms at us
apparently it's going to destroy our
satellites so yeah
right let's hope not
so as always when we do our little live
shows with uh me over here in the uk and
my
i always do go the wrong way
and my uh resident american i'll store
me bear
hello hello what have you been watching
in the last couple of weeks the last
couple weeks you know i made up a clever
little list here and just a track i've
caught up with um killing eve which is
not exactly sci-fi but
it's like
that's how this series is more sci-fi
than right here right now
kill and eve is kind of like you know
sean connery era
cold war 007 mixed in with uh slapstick
comedy
yeah i think it looks best in a love
story yeah that's so it's really
interesting
uh you got caught up with uh picard
this uh
this last week
i'm not enjoying picard you know what
after an opening episode which i
creamed up i went nuts over i
immediately did a video and told
everybody how how much i loved it feels
good
i've been a bit disappointed
since
the the um last couple episodes
you know kind of focused on you know
crystal ball in the hands of ice you
know
here in america that's the
uh the immigration control authority
and it was so much like watching you
know hear local news you know he again
in california and there's just oh oh
look there's an ice agent you know
dragging the family hispanics you know
behind them to throw them in a truck to
take them someplace it's like is this
the news
i just thought they were um is this are
they just making the voyage home
are they gonna rescue some whales in a
minute yeah i even
maybe so um
you never know um
i'll save a goldfish it'll be a goldfish
or something like that to save the
future and that's what they'll have to
they'll and they'll have to make some
transparent aluminum
just for you that was that's right i
said illumina even though it made me it
hurt me inside
i i saw the the anguish across your
flash
clear aluminum which is actually now a
thing
someone's invented it yep standard on
your tesla cyber truck
yeah exactly that's actually amazing
nice i love star trek
um i i watched the moon night
i watched that episode speaking of
goldfish
oh yeah yes
he grew back a fin i didn't really get
that bit
um
i love that i thought that was really
good um
it's a bit slow my kids didn't really my
kids watched it even though it was 16
yeah
and i was just hoping for no boobs and
there wasn't any stuff that's that's all
i would my kids understand like violent
but they're 13 they're young adults they
understand the violence and isn't real
and everything but i just get a bit
awkward if there's anything like
nudity or anything
some 15's got to be really careful
um but yeah i love the little references
a little little avatar reference and
yeah and a few other things and the
actor who was in june wasn't as well
he's a brilliant actor so um i know i
think that's got a lot of um
a lot of drama in that series i think
it's going to be good i love the lasso i
love the the fine little scene when it
becomes moon night and that monster
thing goes in and then you just hear bam
bam bam and then you just see the
monster story trying to get out
well you know the monsters only on the
tile floor scratching to get away and it
was just like that was a clever little
scene
that was a nice little scene
and all the all the times he fell asleep
and everyone when he woke up everyone
was battered
well if you watch
well one one last thing about picard is
the thing i uh
uh last episode of picard you can't go
wrong when you have seven and nine in an
la cop chase you know that was kinda
cool you know free waste uh a freeway uh
uh chase that was awesome
and um
the i'm kind of sad that the poor queen
got shot in the neck
yeah
yeah
because her call
well there is the guy now before we go
on to our weekly topic this week's topic
i don't i it annoys me when they mess
with cannon why couldn't she have just
recognized him
why did they have to pretend like
i know the whole thing was then that it
was his name that made her go oh um
um
you know um good evening peter how are
you sir hello peter
we'll get onto the games very shortly um
but yeah um i don't know why they just
had to change canada i'm not a big one
for i'm not desperate other canon always
has to be followed regardless but don't
change it for absolutely no reason it's
a bit that's a bit irritating you know
it's like
they they could have very easily stepped
around that and they just chose to it's
like they forgot
a bit
especially when you know in next
generation
when a guy in was when they met gainen
in um
1800 san francisco yeah it was like
you know okay yeah it's
more you know it's 100 years or whatever
or 200 years since you've met in about
150 years since you met them
you'd remember she'd remember because
you know you she remembers and
she talks a lot
again how could you forget you know
meeting data in data's head while you're
with uh mark twain prancing around you
know
the market she's just been drinking a
lot
well she wasn't able
yeah exactly so
oh well
um
is that something troubling we should be
maybe that's what she has i mean next
generation at a bar right
um
in the 90s in 2024 she was in a bar she
was still in the same bar 200 years
later that's right
so yeah girl can't move on
yeah that girl is an alcoholic and
that's the problem that's why she's
forgot the card we figured it out
look and i keep wondering if you're
setting up to something you know for the
bell riots you know from ds9 yeah um it
does feel along those lines and that
would actually be that would actually be
pretty cool it's that thing's throughout
year isn't it yeah
the events i think are nine months apart
yeah so i mean that's that's very
possible and definitely race and i know
people have already started to shout
that it's woke um
but i think it's very relevant
um to
the world right now and the race
yeah oh
i'm sorry my alarm just went off
um
you're late i can't hear you now one
second
again once it is
sorry about that you're back i'm back i
think excellent thank you sorry about it
i've never got a horrible feeling that
alarm is going to go off again in a
second
oh well never mind it was an alarm to
tell me to be ready for this
uh right so
um hey hello okay
last week now you've seen it i've seen
it i haven't
because i'm an idiot and i can't be
bothered to get a vpn which would be
very easy for me to do
we're not going to get halo until
paramount plus
comes to the uk
um which will be apparently in the next
month
oh well yeah
and i'm getting it because i've got sky
and i've already got i have sky movie
package and it's going to be part of the
sky movie package so if you're in the uk
that's how you're going to be able to
watch carmo plus
you have seen it though so did you enjoy
it
yes i did the i played the video game
god knows how long ago but back
i think i played the video game back
where the xbox 360 was the thing to have
um
it was okay it was okay for a game i
mean the reason i got halo was because
i'm a big fan of larry niven's ring
world series the book
books i should say and it was okay it's
essentially you know it it's a
first-person shooter on a hamster wheel
that's what the game was
i saw the i said oh boy they made a
series
how horrible is this going to be so i
you know
just sat down and forced myself to watch
it
and it was really good
there was like a story in everything
exposition
yes exposition characters you hated
characters you kind of liked
monsters
it was i want monsters i do i i really
did enjoy it
and the only thing i need to complain
about somebody was a yelling um he takes
his helmet off
a lot and he's not supposed to and i'm
like
pretty sure in the later games he did
take his helmet off i think so
um but anyway um but but yeah i think
and if that's really your biggest
problem with the show
right
yeah
but that is a nice little segway into
this week's topic
yes
film disaster allies likes it not a
giant halo game fan but the series has
got it hooked so far i am going to vpn
um
so we're going to be talking about video
games being turned into movies or tv
series whichever you like i don't think
there's many tv series halo is one of
the first ones really isn't i can't
think of anything i'm sure there have
been
um but games have been turned into
movies or movies i would like to mention
movies turning into games at some point
because i've got a gripe about when they
turn
games
yeah games into movies they sometimes do
it well but anyway
but
so
movies that have been two games first of
all which ones have you
no let's start with hated
hate it hated so good
conversation
i'm gonna well we'll have to pick on the
focus once
the street fighter movie
yeah i it was
film hurt me yeah it like physically
hurt me uh
it was like somebody connected me to the
mains
and by my testicles
um and and flip the switch it was awful
moving but you know i i i got the i went
on wikipedia and it was reading about it
um
the person who i who jumped out to me
that was like oh my god i can't believe
she was in it
um
ming now when
isn't it really
she played um chun li
um and she looks exactly the same the
same yes god jesus that was my next
question
you know it's um
i i
i really tried watching it a long time
ago but i think i fell asleep on the
couch or something because it was not
that it was not riveting at all it was
like
it's a terrible movie but you know the
one nice story about that film which i
do like was um
julia who um obviously played bison i am
bison um he was actually really really
poorly and when they made that film he
he had cancer and he died not long after
and he didn't want to do the film but
they basically drove up to the back of
his house with a dumper truck full of
money i went please please please do the
film um and he only did it
because he wanted
like to be able to give his family you
know one less decent pay packet sort of
thing um
and i and it's a sad story of sad little
background to the movie sort of thing
but um
but yeah and jean-claude van damme was
awful in it and um kylie minogue was in
it and other than that
there is nothing memorable about that
film at all it's it's it's just awful
there's
[Music]
i'm trying to think if it was
i'm trying
i'm looking at rael julia how do you
spell here hey
r-a-u-l
julia
this guy played um
gomez
right
he was brilliant in those absolutely
brilliant in the uh
in those films
there's another one i thought he did in
a for a video game
that's on my list
[Music]
mussolini
kiss the spider woman tempest
apparently not
okay well paralyzed has actually come
out with a movie that's even worse oh
goodness
what sorry
oh goodness
go ahead pyramid came a little bit was
actually worse
the mario for this movie
well see that's the one i thought ral
julia was in that's on my list too um no
it's a bob hoskins dennis hopper um
john
who is actually brilliant actors in that
dennis hopper brilliant actor uh when
he's doing it he's one of those over
acting things yeah
and he's done some god-awful films um
but when he's on it when he's doing a
film he's you know he's he's a great
actor um bob hoskins great actor but
again
he's done some movies because they've
given him a massive pay packet and i
think this is one of them
but john
leguiza um is he's a great actor he's
brilliant um you know he's properly
intense and this these were awful movies
and there's lots of rumors again about
the mario brothers movie there's a lot
going on behind the scenes um you know
um
there was directors and everything and
i just have to quickly block some
comments that are popping up thank you
very much
um it was also uh
fiona shaw was in that movie she um
was in the harry potter film she was
also in one of the protagonists in
killing eve
okay yes
um
yes she was good in that actually um yes
she's got um and she was in two men and
a little lady
two men yeah i think that's right yep um
let me just get rid of this guy
sorry
an error occurred while trying to
refresh the page
there you go that one needs to go but
anyway
right
so that's a couple of movies that have
been really bad you know another film i
hated which i was really looking forward
to and they spent they spent a lot of
money on um it's only a few years ago uh
warcraft
dude um okay warcraft that's the video i
was playing warcraft right before we
came on
now i was i was really man you know i
was hoping i had really good high hopes
for this
and deep under my cynical heart i just
knew it was just going to be [ __ ] and
i i you know and and
i think the director was uh david bowie
son is that correct
yes yeah yeah yeah it was yeah and uh i
don't know jason momoa played one of the
one of the characters or didn't you
think yeah
characters but it was god it was bad
well you're right quickly sorry i'm
going to get back
she's turning the alarm off this time i
knew i'd snoozed into the turn there
did i get dumped in the harbor again you
did it's because i'm so professional oh
and i'm ready to do the live shows i
have to use my phones it's just much
easier um but i did forget about them
anyway
um
the paralyzed the warcraft movie wasn't
bad but it needed more story that was i
think that it looked nice
it is well put together
yeah exactly the cgi was great
um all that sort of thing it's just i
think paralysis got it bang on there
there just wasn't like enough to there's
no depth to it
the the thing they tried i think
critically i think they try to do too
much i mean you know
warcraft has had
plethora of expansions a bunch of
foundational um games you know
uh orcs versus humans when it all
started out and
there was so much story there
i think they try to compress everything
into one big gigantic or origin story
and it just didn't it should have
focused on one thing
you know and
but it is it was just too much to get it
was just too compressed i think
i thought it was a bit two-dimensional
for me and um they
i mean like like
oh
mad jam jar
good name
it's got it though they're great action
sequences to be fair so if you watch it
as a popcorn movie just yeah popcorn
turn brain off
yep
the the fight scenes were great but it
was almost like they got oh we can do
these amazing fight scenes so let's just
focus on that and i think we we've
talked about it a couple times sometimes
they've got cgi in a movie and it's just
like the film becomes about that the
technology rather than um
[Music]
the story and the story's got to come
first yeah
oh he's back again we've got out i'm
getting there we're getting hacked
um but anyway we must be popular
i i tell you what my my channel's doing
so well now i'm i'm gonna become a bit
of a big-headed youtuber i'm gonna be
able to quit my job soon and live off
this because the amount of spots put in
bloody um
things something i must be huge
why can't i hear there's nine people
watching right now
i won't but
yeah
you can have mine i'll pass them over as
long as you're watching my
videos and liking them and commenting
and
yes please and if you i say if you're
watching the video right now and you're
new to the channel please like subscribe
and obviously go over to psyworks
that way the
link is in the description you can go
and subscribe to our stormy our resident
american um and if you want to support
the channel so you can hit the join
button please feel free it gives me a
warm fuzzy feeling inside when people he
needs a warm fuzzy feeling today
i do i do it's been it's been a long day
um i like my new my new t-shirt a logo
designed by one of my amazing
subscribers i've completely rebranded
the channel in the last week
and i'm very happy
sidetrack me
why i'm sure that's not a why sidetray
no it's trendy
shut up stormy
it looks great
um
and i like purple so that's all good
um shelly heinz has just become a new
member see she's doing it she's told
well done
thank you shelley i love you um shelley
runs our facebook channel um you can
actually go and join us on facebook and
she does an amazing job she really
really looks after us thank you so much
shelley i actually feel bad taking money
off you um
so we were bitching about uh mario
brothers super mario brothers yes yeah
it was filmed in wilmington north
carolina now i was working in wilmington
film at the time did not work on the
movie but oh my god it was a monkey
circus the seven you mentioned that you
actually were in and around it
yeah yeah yeah um
i was mostly you know all the stuff i
learned in silicon in semi valley uh
that back in the day on uh special prop
effects
and that's uh so i just started doing
the same thing in wilmington back in the
day
and it was i mean the super mario
brothers it was a [ __ ] show i mean he
had lots of money lots of i mean like
you mentioned dennis hopper which was a
resident of middle of wilmington north
carolina at the time
he lived on figure 8 island where all
the movie stars lived he had a really
nice art gallery showing some of his own
artwork and
i was he was multi-talented he was
really good
acting graphic arts
uh super mario bros at the time was
filmed on the world's largest green
stream which was at carroll cove studios
yeah you could tell
but
that said
it just did not come together
at all i mean it was
a disaster production was after i would
actually it was from
day one
um it's one of those films that they
just messed up from the beginning and to
be honest the the the first mistake was
deciding to make it
it's it's it was they made it because
it was it was the biggest video game in
the world at the time and they had to
make it and what they shouldn't have
done it doesn't somebody who makes
movies would have gone well i would make
it this way this is going to work um but
they just did it anyway
terrible movie badly made
bad cgi
but um is the movie then think did you
see
the doom movie now gamer beans here
didn't like that film
i did
i really liked it
um
but there is a scene in it that i hated
which one was it
i have a bit of i've actually talked
about this in a in a video i did a
couple weeks ago i've got a pet hate
when they make movies like this and then
they try to do something from the genre
right so i think i mentioned to you they
when they did the thunderbirds movie
right yeah this has been the easiest
film in the world to make um uh our
jonathan frakes should be
kicked
really hard in delicate places for
cocking that hormone because he directed
it there's a bit in it when the the guy
has a microchip in the back of his head
and he sort of walks around like this
like he's a remote controlled
there's a little bit of a thing back to
the movie didn't need to do it look
stupid they did something similar in
doom when they have the bit um these uh
carl urban is running around shooting
all the monsters so they do a bit where
it's looking down the barrel of the gun
right and he said thing and he's playing
it looks like the game if it wasn't
necessary they shouldn't have done it
and it just stuck out like a sore thumb
in the film
the film itself is actually quite good
the rock's quite good in it and i say
kyle gleben's brilliant i really like
carl urban
he's one of those actors that i think's
never quite made a list he's all been in
and around it um and i wish he'd
you know i think he deserves to get bit
more respect than he does
um because i think khalid and one of
those great actors but i actually
quite liked the film
um except for that bit
well my my critique uh about the film is
the same as yours now i think i watched
it on dvd the expanded edition or the
direct whatever
or it had like 15 more minutes of
footage and the 15 more minutes of
footage was literally
the twitch like first person shooter
scene
only thing that was missing was the
swearing of the twitch streamer you know
and and and that was that's all the last
of it was and it really did remind me of
uh
now it reminds me of what a twitch
stream is sans all the swearing and
cursing and
yeah you know it was just
i do like the game though
i love the game afternoon that was one
of my favorite games um
i understand that they should make well
i'll talk about games that they're
they're going to be making into movies
at the end but duke nukem was a game i
always loved
and i always think that should be that
should be a film yeah but a comedy you
know like a bit of a ridiculous like a
bit of a thing but uh but yeah i would
have loved seeing robin williams play
duke
yeah oh my god i could say that that way
i mean with him just you know running
off you know just you know ad-libbing
everything robin william
yeah if you did a better job than you
did in the popeye movie that was he was
the only good thing in the popeye movie
um
i feel that actually well we're talking
about films that were pretty bad but i
actually quite liked um did you see wing
commander
with freddie prince jr i did
and um
i was the other fellow in it
really hard matthew large isn't it as
well yeah
or the guy that played the paladin what
was
he was in he's been a bunch of science
fiction things like the core i think he
was ah okay i'm not sure um that was a
filmer that was um
it was maybe a little bit too
similar to the the game
and they maybe should have
um
[Music]
come away from the game they should have
been like inspired by the game and i
think they did it quickly but actually i
really like parts of it i really like
the cgi and a lot of the sci-fi i like
to have that they launched torpedoes
and the torpedo would come out of the
torpedo tube and sort of drop slightly
like it was like there was gravity in
space and then the rocket would ignite
and go sure but it looked cool and i'm
like um yeah the science you messed up
there with the special effects a little
bit but you know like you forgot there's
no gravity in space
but it looked cool um
in that way that's the thing i remember
that i haven't seen for 20 years and i
always remember thinking it was really
good i was shamely there was always
trying to get a sequel but it never
quite got off the ground yeah
but freddie prince jr who's against one
of those actors i always like him in
front of him he did a series of 24 he
was really good in that
um that's right i forgot he did him
special appearances as um i think it was
bones
he kept appearing on every so often
there's like an fbi agent and he's again
he's one of those actors that i think he
again i wish i'd seen him in more things
really i think he could have actually
got a reasonably good action here if he
got the right movie he needed that bruce
willis type of part you know
um or something but he could have he
could have done something i'd like to
see him like instead of brendan fraser
in them
in the mummy or something like that i
think you'd have worked really well yeah
um
yeah there you go paralyzed first rule
sci-fi movies will always be
physics doesn't matter so
the uh the guy i'm thinking of there was
in that that i really liked i'm trying
to pronounce his name right is
chica
carro caro t-c-h-e-k-y
k-a-r-y-o
okay he's also in la femme nikita uh the
patriot he's mostly a french actor
there's a lot of french films oh i know
what you mean but right you know and but
he i thought he was i really didn't like
him in wing commander
you know he i think he played the
character i guess his code name was
pallet and i don't recall his
actions
so what what any games you then that
that they're so bad you love the penny
so bad i love them um
okay
i don't think this was a bad movie and
you're gonna get hate miller with this
i don't think i was fine
detective pikachu
right [ __ ] i looked up for this the
research for this i googled top 10 games
movies turned from games this by big
games number one yeah detective pikachu
but i did question the list a little bit
in that um uh
mario brothers and um street fighter
both appeared on the same list as the
top ten best i was like the person that
did this and warcraft appeared on it as
well yeah yeah personally wrote this
list has been drinking
um
but but yeah i detective pikachu is um
if i make spencer from aliens um and
stuff is watching this he would be
jumping up and down right now because he
loves that movie
great movie um
it's just awesome
yeah
i don't know what cameron which movie
camera is to talk about that one i don't
know if it's picture pikachu or wink
might have book
it's one of those films i i probably
wouldn't watch again but i enjoyed
thoroughly and i hope they make a sequel
and i would watch that thoroughly i
wanted to watch um to take pikachu at
the cinema because i'm a huge white
men's fan i love ryan
um
and my wife wouldn't let me
she wouldn't go with me
i should just go on my own
i love that just because
what they did was they they direct so
we've got to take a pikachu and we've
somehow managed to talk ryan reynolds
into making it let's just let ryan
reynolds run with it
yeah
and then
all they did basically right try not to
swear too much other than that crack on
something and it's you know it made it
it made a really really good movie it's
a fun film
um and yeah detective pikachu yeah it's
i wouldn't watch it again either camera
um but um
they just yeah they just i think they
just kept it simple without reasonably
they made a movie they didn't over
complicate the story too much they had a
nice little twist at the end and they
let ryan reynolds be ryan rounds
and it was awesome i loved it yeah yeah
now one
one from a video game to a movie that
just
and they've tried several times and you
know let's hear it for trying multiple
times to get something wrong
tomb raider
yeah i think that's probably one of the
most
successful
attempts at this
definitely going back a few years um
but my jam john ryan reynolds is today's
version adam sandler yeah i think he's
funny
um
was adam sandler ever funding i'm just
trying no
the first angelina jolie
was actually i thought quite good
i loved how they brought it padded her
bra quite a lot
and to try and get it close to the game
and you notice how in the second film
her boobs have shrunk significantly and
as she then got a bit of power and a bit
of control and went you know what i'm
not wearing a three-inch padded bra
um
but
the um oh it's also the film i think the
first one that probably got daniel craig
the james bond gig
because i mean nobody really knew what
daniel craig was and he there is a scene
in that movie where he gets his drop off
um and it was released but he's quite
muscular everyone's there and he's an
old man there but um i it wasn't long
after that he got the james bond gig so
uh it's not quite a video game into a
movie but battleship is hilarious
beyond bad
it's a terrible movie i totally forgot i
i guess i blanked out battleship just
yeah well it's a board game so
technically
gamer you're not allowed that comment
well i think that battleship was also on
uh
i think it was on a game boy
i stand corrected i apologize um it
was
stupid
and beyond stupid um
it was it was like
the person
that wrote it had a brain injury
and i mean that with all the due respect
to people who have suffered you know we
think i work in that sort of area people
you know
um but it was just stupid they were like
i've got to make a battleship game yeah
can i just be inspired by it and do
something else no no you have to be
exactly like a battlefield game
everything we have to make a board game
somehow
effing kidding me how do i make a board
game aliens oh
right um it's just it it it's just bad
and it's it's a bad when rihanna is the
best thing in the film that's bad
um good evening ian how are you doing
sir
yeah yeah we're so late what are you
doing come on man you're half hour late
get with it
well what do you know it's fine because
when we're done go back and start
watching the film from the beginning for
me for the serious thing you know thank
you that'd be good
um
go back to tomb raider tomb raider yes
if you insist
i send it off halfway through the third
one
now um i did not see the last one with
the new actress alicia vince
was that any good
actually i turned it off with where i
got bored oh that was the one you turned
off at me um they're getting a sequel i
make another one oh she's a good actress
she's a great actress
it's just completely unbelievable
the action scenes are this scrawny
little girl is getting thrown around and
just
there's a bit where she jumps from the
ship at one point she has to scramble to
survive something she jumps about 30
feet
i mean just watching her
this is a transformers movie we're just
like that's just ridiculous that doesn't
make any sense
um
speaking of jumping 30 feet
one that was just a movie that was
atrocious
atrocious even worse than i think the
any kind of transformer i mean excuse me
any kind of tomb raider
she's not you're talking about version
number three
prince of persia
that was
weird i like i really like jake
gyllenhaal but there are certain films
he shouldn't do he's not he's not he's
the wrong sort of actor i just saw an
ambulance at the cinema with him in and
he's really good
is it good okay yeah he's pretty good in
it um i don't like uh michael mann
michael bay films and it's just it's
directed like a michael bay film i don't
like him as a director particularly yeah
um it's very jerky and jumps out like
the trans but um but it's yeah it's
actually pretty good it works because
you keep the tension going keep the
tension going sort of thing
um
but um check killing horn in that film
it was just like
i i yeah i think maybe that was it he
just
uh he just didn't sell the role you know
i'm trying to be you know some woke
thing that oh he was the wrong race or
whatever he's kind of probably not
you know
from that part of the world and they try
to make him up to be like that like
elizabeth taylor and um
cleopatra
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i always said moses for a while
she played clay patrick
if that wasn't the name of the film or
not but um but yeah um no i know what
you mean they did they give them a good
time didn't they and they're gonna they
wanna crack on you'll be fine no one
will notice yeah no one will notice they
basically
i'm like i'm pretty sure that's not
allowed anymore
um it wasn't i i wasn't a big fan of
prince of persia i didn't think it quite
worked you know another film that i
think they got wrong was actually quite
a good film but i think they got the
casting wrong and they just checked my
list assassin's creed
michael fassbender
yeah
it's not a bad film i was a bit confused
by it in places because i never really
played the game so i'm assuming people
that played the game or understood all
the time travelly bits
um but i just don't think michael
fassbender was very good in it i think
he was the wrong actor um
there was i i i played the video game a
little bit and uh actually it was the
one in the stage in colonial america so
uh it was
i just i don't know man it it didn't
seem to sync with what the video game
was it tried to be maybe something else
or go beyond or something maybe fast
vendors acting
i didn't think the writing was all there
i don't know it just it did not
yeah
i think quite really
quite why
um we'll come back to that in a second
though
before we start talking about something
else
the the one of my favorite movies
and series of movies from a game is
resident evil
um mila mila jovovich i just thought she
played such an amazing part in that that
that links up to monster hunter actually
which i did see recently i actually
really enjoyed um and again mila
jovovich was just fantastic in it um
but um the only thing with monster unto
us i suppose it was a bit over the top
in places with some of them some of the
monsters but that was the point
um but um the resident evil particularly
the first one
um was just stunning the other ones
maybe suffered for not having a big
enough budget but um
and the first one was i mean
she can always carry those films you
know she you know it's like her part and
she
regardless how many they make and
everyone i've seen she's actually
carrying the story quite well
yeah she's such a great she is a really
good actress um and she's physically
very imposed i think so she i mean she
physically makes those films work but um
but yeah my son is pretty good but there
isn't evil films they are making a
fifth one
i think so
third or fourth or fifth um so we'll see
if that's supposed to be the first one
um but yeah i think everyone's going to
agree that it was just a good film um it
was well made it was really
um
loyal to this story it was a story it
was a game that actually worked as a
film because the story worked as a film
i mean i think the game was done in a
very theatrical
thematic way so it helped
which goes on to what i was just gonna
speak about before i talk about again
what games are coming up
is a is the problem why a lot of these
games into movies doesn't work
because
they're too maybe sometimes too loyal to
the original it's sometimes like when um
we've talked before the the stream
started
when they turn
books into movies novels into movies
sometimes there can be an argument to
say that that people moaned either no
they've changed it too much the harry
potter's people go on and on and on
about how much you change it too much so
they're all the rings anything talking
but also yeah exactly or they they re
really strictly stick to the book and
then everyone knows
that didn't really work and the ends
i'm thinking like angels and demons or
tom hanks and things like they stuck to
the book yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and then but it pisses off towards
the end of it and it's like this
anticlimactic end and it's because yeah
because it doesn't a book doesn't
necessarily translate
like like onto one to one something you
need to make changes to make it fit a
different
genre don't you know is that the same
with games sometimes
i
i think
i think so i mean you know games just
another form of storytelling if it's
done right unless it's i don't know
snake on your nokia phone maybe there's
no story to be they had there
but the ones that
the ones that are really good all right
every color
snakes on a plane left on it
you know i think the problem like going
back to warcraft was they tried to
squeeze the whole game into less than a
couple hours
you know we know some a game you know
like the the current version or the
curtain release of uh warcraft is uh
shadowlands
you know and to do go through all of
that including the last patch
i mean that's takes more than a year
to play
a year
to do it well and follow all the quests
and follow all the stories and you know
so how are you ever going to get the
entirety of warcraft into under two
hours
not sure how
um books i think are easier maybe than
uh video games because you do have a
book
to go through
yeah you know
there's a story sometimes there aren't
even that many
stories there's not that much storage
some of these games
you know it's true because because it's
a game it's something
right
checkers
how much storage is an ad
i think they're all technically a
computer we're being really technical
with that yeah
okay so
you know
again snake was
that's a game but it's
there's no it's just pure entertainment
you know it's it's it's it's just to
help us with our attention span of a
goldfish these days um
what am i saying it's it does
it does make sense
that um
that it's difficult to transfer against
particularly when they try to be like
that's what we said about mario brothers
wasn't it
yeah it didn't fit but because it was so
popular they had to make it they decided
no we're making anyway and that's just
that's when it goes wrong but then you
get other films
like i don't know if you saw recently um
the werewolves within
was quite loosely based on it on a
vr game actually
um but what they did was they they took
a game
and they made a movie they didn't make a
movie about the you know they didn't
make a game movie they just really
that's that's great
really great title
um
mad jam jar i think that's a good point
so all the trouble to say that um you
know they that's true but it made a film
that was
loosely based on the game it's like the
guy was it's like the guy who's playing
the game i thought this would make a
great movie and wrote a script
right we've got a game and we have to
make a movie and we'll get this square
peg and we'll jam it as hard as we can
as that round hole until we get
something comes out the other end um
so sometimes
yeah i i kind of agree with that because
i think that sometimes in these video
game movies the filmmakers aren't fans
of the game
um
you know
and i think sometimes it really does
show they're just hired to do a job
aren't they basically yeah it feels like
yeah definitely that with mario brothers
they just had to make a movie regardless
how
um
the the
investment thing and the the the how
much money some of these games have
um some of these movies have i do think
that's a good point i do think in the
past they have really small budgets uh
or budgets that meant that they couldn't
quite because obviously in a video game
there's quite dramatic things happening
you know so it's quite good sci-fi quite
big special effects are needed
um and they don't have the funds i'm
thinking the first mortal kombat
and definitely the second one but that
was awful that was just a that was just
a let's make a sequel um film um
retaliation or something like that was
called um
but that film really suffered because
they basically gave christopher lambert
all the money
and didn't have any money left to make
the film so they just made a bad film
but is that because
i mean that also you should say the
first mortal kombat movie was the most
popular video game movie
up until only like a couple of years ago
um until the last mortal kombat came out
i think overtook it and uncharted
overtook it it that was them that was
the film that made the most money so a
lot of these films
failed
yeah you know they didn't get made you
know thinking
they made that crazy birds movie is that
crazy birds that's what it's called
angry birds angry birds thank you very
much
just because angry birds was popular so
they made a film
it didn't work even remotely
and it didn't make any money so is that
a problem
is that maybe why some of these films
haven't worked
i think some producers just see you know
how hey this is trending on google let's
make a movie i think that was angry
words came out i was just like oh here's
something popular
is it also a kids show now also
yes i think so yeah i think they sort of
turn into a kids show which again they
do that sometimes don't they when a
movie doesn't do very well they turn
into a kitchen
um
but yeah all right um
so recently though
um uncharted did come out i did see that
in cinema did you okay it's a game i've
never played
the movie was
um
um
the um
at two main actors whose name tom
holland is basically you can do anything
at the moment and it'll it'll make money
um and the other fella whose name's
gonna have my head i've got picture in
him
dang it um but anyway one of the biggest
actors in hollywood in my car marky mark
mark wahlberg thank you um
so
yeah um
but to be honestly though the film is
quite forgettable
the pop is
basic um it's it's a it's they're
hunting for gold and things and they're
just they're just treasure hunters it's
kind of been done
um
yeah
and but yeah entertaining movie i didn't
want my money back when i left the
cinema at the end of the day which is
always a good mark i i didn't go up to
reception and demand my money back which
i did do once actually right um
what what movie was that you demanded
your money
but it was actually ryan reynolds wasn't
it
um it was based on a it was a fun fair
or something and ryan reynolds was in it
and
kristen stewart
who does do you remember friends when um
joey was talking about you did act in
class
any one of the things was he says if
ever you um there's a dramatic moment
you just smell the fart acting and you
just sort of get
and you pretend like you're smelling the
fart and wondering where it's come from
and that's how you sell a dramatic
moment i think that's how kristen
stewart acts i think she actually saw
that and when i i will do that
and she's terrible but this film
whatever the hell it was called it was
it was advertised like it was a
screwball comedy it was a very early one
early early for ryan reynolds right um
and but it's not it's a teen drama it's
very dramatic and it's full of them
and uh and i did my money back and they
didn't weirdly they said no
um but i wanted my money back it was
terrible
um
so but uncharted did really well and it
smashed records for this type of thing
we're going to be getting a lot
of video game movies
coming up in the next few years would
you like to hear a list
let me go for it tell me anything that
jumps out
um the division
who our favorite actor jake gyllenhaal
is signed up to do which is a
post-apocalyptic
there's a virus
another virus movie thank you yeah yeah
so that's not been done though so that's
unique i'm looking forward to it's
exciting um there's going to be a
minecraft movie now
if there's a if there's a game that they
go we've got to make it and i don't care
how
that's going to be that um
there's going to be a metal gear solid
movie oh
i've lost it the americans died
i'm still recovering from the [ __ ]
minecraft oh my god it'll be awesome
shut up there'll be a dramatic that's
going to win an oscar
um
should i slap somebody now please
and then the director will just [ __ ]
slap hey
i have baldness can i when do i get to
beat the [ __ ] out of someone i mean you
know it's just
that's i that's a very political
statement but it is
actually i would say will smith has
appeared in loads and loads of sci-fi
movies so we could probably like talk
about this um i thought it was staged
and now it looks like no
no
well you know i knew at one stage when i
heard the microphone hit
yeah you know because you because i i
got a hold of like the the uh unedited
version that they didn't you know the
raw feed
and you know you see cl chris rocks the
shock wave go across his face and you
hear the
on the microphone i go oh yeah
that was an impact
yeah he did catch him but he slapped him
like such a will smith is a big fella he
really shouldn't
knock yeah chris rock skinny little
fella on his ass
you know after the slap you know also um
he had his arm in
his this this arm here and a defensive
uh posture because you because you know
will smith has taken a lot loads of uh
martial arts classes
for whatever movies
he had his arm you know kind of in a
defensive posture after he just gave uh
chris rock the hollywood bit slap i mean
it was
it was only when he then sat down and
went keep my wife's name out of your
mouth then i thought oh it's not staged
i wonder
said it twice yeah as a big childish
girl i mean that's that's hard i i just
thought it was bad and then i was
reading all about their relationship i'm
like
he didn't mind keeping someone else's
private parts out of her mouth just that
it wouldn't just be me
so i guess i'm in the smith household
morality is on something like
unbelievable
okay who asked us guru next i would like
to now apologize
and i'm not saying the jada pink and
smith is go on
i think she looks right now wolfe is in
jail
yeah she looks evil i'm pretty sure if
jade plinkett smith told me give me all
your money and then look to me i just
would
you just got evil eyes man i'll just be
like whatever you want them just get out
of my jesus
um but yeah
anyway the views of my resident american
friend are his own and they don't
necessarily reflect the views of this
channel
no matter how much jay is giggling about
it
very true um but yeah um he's basically
not going to be seeing any and we'll
switch in any films for a while anyway
you know because they've all been
cancelled
i mean yeah everything he had like in
pre-production
we really paying you 40 million dollars
yeah
it's just said exactly the same point
yeah i've all been cancelled
um
i'll carry on with this anyway so metal
gear solid so yeah
snake oscar isaac is going to be
starring and derek connolly who wrote
jurassic world is down to right so
that's going to happen
uh splinter cell which is a very similar
movie to a metal gear solid splinter
ceiling that uh tom clancy property
uh yes exactly so we'll see
that because they're the all the
uh the from the the game studio that
produced all that used to be in north
carolina raleigh north carolina and uh
typically all those video games in the
past have had a lot of story behind them
yeah i'm usually impressed by current
events um and a couple of these
projects have already been turned into
moves in there i think so yeah we'll see
how that works yeah that might work
um
call of duty is going to be made into a
film yeah those three pharaohs have
quite a lot of story to them but
um mass effect which is a game i never
played that's going to be made into a
movie
gears of war is actually happening soon
that might be the next big one we see on
our screens
portal
which my kids play and they try to
explain it to me and um i had to get
them to explain to me again i i have no
freaking clue what that game's about
there's little robots in it and stuff
and almost like
there is a plot to it
i didn't understand it
um but i'm old so i'm not supposed to
and sleeping dogs
there is
a um rumors of a command and conquer
video game
which actually was my favorite game when
i was a kid i i loved conquering it at
least it has some history behind it you
know yeah yeah i want to see i can't
remember the character's name man the
little psycho russian with the two guns
that used to run around
um it was the one character you could
build she's one of the special things
you could build it yeah run off and just
go crazy i want to see her so that would
be great
um and
uh is it the link character i've written
link down because i know that i know the
game i can't remember the damn name i
don't think that's the name of it but
that's going to be apparently made
that's going to be very um
lord of the ringsy
style i think it's one of my kids
favorite games as well and that is
apparently also rumored to be in
pre-production
so out of that
incredibly long list i can't believe
fortnight isn't on that list it's one of
the most
you know
biggest games of the last five years and
they're not making a film on it
i don't know why but um but apparently
that i couldn't find any rumors about
that anyway
uh call of duty will make a micro
transactions bill to continue watching
the film every 15 minutes
that's at 11.
um
yeah
zelda thank you zelda games
zelda they're gonna be making a zelda
game
and that is apparently
very very um on the cards to be made
very shortly
thank you everybody um so anything in
that list that excites you anything that
lists that makes you want to cry other
than minecraft
the man the command and uh conquer i
think has the highest hope
i i'd love to see that game you know i'd
love to see it if you like i always see
i kind of see it as like you know an
analogy of a
master and commander
you know yeah
the book series that then and that got
turned into a movie
yeah um
also kind of enjoy
um i just want to see tesla towers and
tesla tanks and
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that would be
we've mentioned all of these games has
gone into a movie so how do we reconcile
the issue of steven spielberg's ready
player one
because that's almost like the world the
wrong way around isn't it that was like
the other way around it was a all right
it was every
pop culture reference yes 20 years
especially the la the last battle i mean
it was
every kind of video game character you
can imagine
and i'll tell you what i think it
genuinely is the future as well my son
uh recently got an oculus
vr
thing
300 quid i can't recommend it enough
it's fantastic um i've got a there's a
rocky game and i was playing the rocket
game and this big guy came up and
started swinging at me and i genuinely
went oh
i'm tucked
it was so realistic it was like
oh this gave me a little bit it's vr is
stunning in it vr games are the way to
go man they're going to be they're the
future um and
and you can buy vests that that have
impacts and stuff and uh
i think they're so immersive
um
so yeah i think they're the future and
ready player one
is probably
i i don't think that's the world i don't
think that's that you know exactly like
that but video gaming is vr i don't see
but i think entertainment will be vr i
could imagine watching watching a movie
through vr and actually being able to
turn my head and look at things
will happen
well it's like you know long time ago
video games surpassed hollywood in terms
of uh
income
industry value long time ago
you know and with the
acquisition by microsoft of
blizzard entertainment warcraft
candy crush
all sorts of things it's
yeah
that puts microsoft with a whole lot of
content and unfortunately yes they do
own minecraft
[Music]
but i think that's the yeah that's the
future and we're gonna that's what we're
gonna get so here's my nightmare we're
gonna be um not just in video games but
movies we're gonna be you know in the
next five years we'll be eat up with
games like ukrainian sniper
russian raw dogs
you know actually another cold war's
kicked off again yeah we will be seeing
that i wonder how long it's going to be
a new a modern cold war movie it's going
to be soon isn't it
um
you know yeah red sparrow recently
that's good i enjoyed that i do yeah
that was a good movie but you know i
think i can imagine vr being it'll be
like the internet it'll take off as soon
as somebody figures out how to make it
into porn
um and then and then it'll they'll it'll
take off then i reckon that's generally
the internet survived because of porn
um and that's that's a sad indictment of
men
if it's not already in porn i'd be
surprised it probably is to be honest
oh oculus porn videos are on pornhub
we suck as a gender
seriously we really suck
all ready to warn him
what will genuinely end the world is
when the first woman becomes telepathic
and reads men's minds
they will kill us all
jesus we suck
yes
that's the first result by the way
forget it as well oh man we're stuck as
a species
so what do you think about them so we're
gonna wrap up there because my dinner is
nearly ready
okay um and it's uh yeah seven o'clock
over here i told my wife i'd be done by
seven i promised hand on heart um yeah
um so um
and it's and i've already failed but
what do you think is the future then of
games i think the history of games into
movies has been generally
great
yeah with one or two
good good things like i genuinely think
the first tomb raider was quite good
um i generally think there's been a
couple of other little things like um
uh sorry resident evil is quite good and
you know what
detective pikachu and detective pikachu
which is the movie we do not
if you could go and google um dp movies
now it comes up detective pikachu
promise let's see dp movie
you'll have to burn your computer
afterwards uh
so um
but what do you think about the future
then i think they have suffered with not
having enough budget but that seems to
be
yeah um
so what do you think about what do you
think the future holds for video games
into movies
okay
he's
yes witcher was awesome lewis hillman is
right on top but yeah it you know it's
just you know
good video games i think the really
immersive ones are storytelling it's
just another version of storytelling and
you know in the last hundred years we
have mixed and matched storytelling
no regardless of the uh the the the
niche or the format
from radio i mean how many shows have
went from radio dramas you know two
comic books two movies the shadow comes
to mind
you know um
and by the way a plug for old time radio
otr search on that there are lots of
really
good dramas good content from 1940s on
radio
and those a lot of those are still
captured and you can download it and
listen to them sci-fi
westerns
mob movies just it's just
so i think in terms of storytelling it's
just well how can we with the new
technology how can we mix it all up
you know we had lord of the rings the
books the movies first then we had it
first there was a cartoon then the
movies
now all sorts of video games and same
with star trek that abysmal mobile app
they've been advertising
everywhere
it's like way to win or something i hate
this game
tap it and coins come up and things you
have to just wait for the next thing to
load it's not a freaking game
the the the ads were compelling but the
game it's not that's a cool game is
awful so i think we're going to have
further mix and match of all types of uh
stories i mean look look at marvel you
know comic books into some of the most
successful movies of all time
yeah so i think it's just we mix i mean
it's not going to end it's going to get
more complex and maybe the people who
make these movies will start to get a
sense on what is going to be a good
film and what's not
also what's going to be a great movie
versus what's going to make a great
series warcraft been a great series
yeah as opposed to a movie and that's
the thing is that we're streaming
services now basically making
mini series rather than movies i mean
that that feels to me like this the way
particularly sci-fi is going to go i
think they're going to move away
from making films as much and they'll
make 10 episode series instead with the
budgets of a movie
and because we love binge watching them
um
let's talk about stargate stargate was
talking and they were going i was
initially were pushing mg and they said
what let's make a movie
and mgm has basically talked him out of
it and gone you know what actually a
series will work and it looks like mgm
have won the argument
that they're going to make a series
instead
yeah that'll have the same impact as a
movie would you know it's like because
they can make that and and it also shows
how many big time movie stars are
appearing in tv series at the moment on
streaming networks because there's not
that stigma anymore it used to be you're
a movie star or you're a tv star and
never the twain show me nowadays you can
do both
um
and maybe so but maybe that'll be a way
for some of these projects to be made in
better ways because they'll do them
a series instead
i think um we're talking about uh what
was the film nice that i enjoyed um
detective pikachu yes that one wing
commander i think would have made a
better tv series
i think
um
but but yeah that's true that's just
true um
one last thing before we go then before
the wife comes to knock the door and
tells me to do not burn the dinner
um
games that have been made from movies so
they make a movie it does well and they
make a game
how
why do they do that that some of them
are so bad and so thrown together
um i think like the matrix game they
made right and was terrible
um
i can't think of many that were any good
i mean there for a while you know uh
walking dead a tv series they had almost
like a new mobile game every season
you know and some were good and about i
mean it's just somewhere you know kind
of quest you know quest like
um i think one was a mmo maybe is it
mobile mmo
yeah it's just
you know if you're making films you know
you want to get the story licensing out
there everybody you know you do the book
you do whatever there's also you license
out the content for a comic book you
know social comic the novelization i
think video games is just another part
of that
you know cash crap exactly cameras it's
just another way of advertising the game
almost
like interactive adverts some of them i
remember but but then sometimes they do
great job but what i think sometimes
what they do is they'll do a video game
either to try to come out about the same
times the game and then they're rubbish
because they rush them or just after but
then sometimes when a film is like
really popular they'll do a game a few
years later even a decade later
the first ghostbusters computer game
when they actually got that awkward and
everyone to do the voices for it as well
it was brilliant
it was you know ghostbusters had been
like 10 years before it was like having
a new movie almost you know it's like
ghostbusters three and it was fantastic
they don't do that enough though because
just like everything else in hollywood
they've got no patience
yeah everything's got you know
everything's riding on the initial
advertising campaign for the movie
so if you also do the book the video
game the mobile game the trading cards
or whatever else
then it's all writing on the same
ad campaign you know in some of these
movies the ad campaign is 100 million
dollars yeah
sometimes i spend almost as much on the
ad campaigns yeah yeah
such as another way of doing it yeah sad
really sad but now sometimes i get it
right and i think that's the same with
them making the moves out of games
sometimes they get it right
let's hope they get it right a bit more
often in the future
and i think getting it right it goes
back to you know does the filmmakers
like the game because
i think one reason why lord of the rings
were so successful wasn't so successful
is
peter jackson actually liked tolkien you
know and he knew what to
what to put in what those what to leave
out you know
it was make great controversy over tom
bombadie where the hell is tom bombadil
there was a reason for that the movie
was already three hours long the next
was going to be another three hours
and um
you know he even though he was a fan he
saw really what part of the thread of
getting to the uh getting to mordor
but it would have been nice if he filmed
all that just put it on dvd and that
would have been awesome but yeah well he
filmed a lot more that he did put on the
extra long dvds and when the
directors got like four and a half hours
oh god it was awesome oh yeah it was
good
um
but but yeah i mean i i think that's
true and i think it's true for
everything you know we talk about
reboots and remakes and all sequels and
all these sorts of things and star trek
reboots and everything else and stargate
and everything else it's got to be made
by somebody that loves what they're
doing if it's if it's made by somebody
that loves the project
it's a lot more likely to
be i always think it's the same as when
i do these videos i don't do videos
to
what i think people will like i do
videos that i like
and then hopefully people will like them
and that's i think that's the only way
to do it it is yeah um
movie makers sometimes will do projects
just because they have to marry brothers
and they
instead of making something they
actually desperately want to make and i
think that's the moral of the story and
that's right i think it is
well there's some of these directors you
know they get into these three uh three
contract deals
you know and then somebody throws oh
yeah you gotta go make warcraft well
that's part of your contract
yeah yeah so i've got no choice i've got
to make it yeah
right that
is where we will leave it for this
evening guys thank you so much for
everybody that's joined us if you are
new to the channel don't forget to like
subscribe share the video wherever the
hell you like and go and
join this little man over here on his
channel and there's a link in the
description and you may learn something
yeah you may not though as well you may
not
i didn't um i didn't lose luna no i did
actually i learned about hydrogen in
your channel um so yeah and you've got
some lovely mysteries and things as well
um
good night everybody i'm so glad you
joined us stormy as always thank you so
so much alan you're very very late
go back and watch it from the beginning
um
it's been
another brilliant conversation and thank
you very much stormy for joining us
thank you for having me i really do
appreciate you in a couple of weeks
next week
i am doing another live video with a um
with our mat who actually runs our
discord server i think i put a link for
the description in that as well so you
can join some discord and we're going to
be talking yeah we are going to be
talking stargate so we're going to talk
about with the new stargate series
hopefully around the corner what do we
want to see so
hopefully i'll join you'll uh you'll
come and join us for that as well
thank you very much we'll see you next
week
toodles wait a second i've got an outro
wait wait there's another one right we
gotta
[Music]